In this lecture, we provide a
quick introduction into the
conceptual framework of
classical statistics.
We use the words "classical" to
make the distinction from
the Bayesian framework that
we have been using so far.
Recall that in the Bayesian
framework, unknown quantities
are viewed as random variables
that have a certain prior
distribution.
In contrast, in the classical
setting an unknown quantity is
viewed as a non-random constant
that just happens to
be unknown.
We can still carry out
estimation without assuming a
prior for the unknown
quantity.
For example, if the unknown
theta is the mean of a certain
distribution, we can generate
many samples from that
distribution and form
the sample mean.
The weak law of large numbers
then tells us that this
estimate will approach in the
limit as n increases the true
value of theta.
After going through this
argument, we will then take
the occasion to introduce some
terminology that is often used
in connection with classical
estimation methods.
Now, the sample mean provides
us a point estimate for the
unknown theta, but does not
tell us how accurate that
estimate is.
To give a sense of the
accuracy involved, we
introduce the concept of a
confidence interval, which is
an interval that has high
probability of containing the
true theta.
In general, it is a common
practice to report not just
estimates, but also confidence
intervals.
But as we will discuss, one
has to be careful in
interpreting what exactly a
confidence interval tells us.
We will see that we can easily
calculate confidence intervals
using the central
limit theorem.
And we will discuss in some
detail some extra steps that
need to be taken if we do not
know the variance of the
random variables involved.
We will then continue in the
direction of greater
generality.
We will see that by repeated use
of various sample means,
we can also estimate more
complicated quantities, such
as, for example, the correlation
coefficient
between two random variables.
We will conclude by introducing
a general
estimation methodology, the
so-called maximum likelihood
estimation method.
This is a method that applies
always, even when the unknown
parameter of interest cannot
be interpreted as an
expectation.
It is a universally-applicable
method.
And fortunately, has some very
desirable properties.